so Fred what was your first thought that
ran through your head when they came to
you with the idea of recreating the
Princess Bride scene where they read you
the story in Deadpool I thought it was a
terrible idea Ryan mentioned to me and I
said oh I don't know why you'd do that
because this is this great family movie
that people love and what you do is this
really kind of over the top you know
gratuitously violent profane thing you
know why would you put those two
together and and he said well they said
the same thing about chocolate and
peanut butter and I said well I don't
know like that combination either
personally myself and so now we're here
I get you know right look Ryan doesn't
take no for an answer
even though you say I mean a lot of
people say no no no no and I did it real
loud he doesn't he's not acolyte
Canadian is what you're saying because
he is our you know he's a beloved
Canadian he is a beloved Canadian but I
would choose Celine Dion
you know I would choose Alanis
Morissette IIIi would choose Dave
Coulier I would choose anything you know
I would you know I mean I think that
there's I spent a lot of time in Canada
I've worked in Canada and I think there
are way better figureheads that you
could rally around as a nation than Ryan
Reynolds I mean he's handsome
okay you know great body you know the
super personality seems like a good dad
but honestly even that superficial it's
superficial what was that first day like
back at your breakfast Richard Dreyfus
is Canadian is he
John Mooney John Candy obviously is when
you wanna leave keep going when you
walked into that set was it like super
Moranis eric mccormack
sorry what did you obtain chef food when
you walked back on set
seeing that bedroom again yeah it was
weird it was weird how they had created
it like they they made the set almost
exactly almost exactly like the other
set it was the panes they took was it
was very strange it was very weird
and Ryan was like this is so weird being
here and I was like it's weird for you
I'm I'm weird for you I'm here a tied to
a bed but he's very focused on himself
not Canadian
not gonna eat at all that's so not good
ad not Canadian at all did you score
major dad points with your kids on this
one I mean Oliver's 12 are you letting
him see the movie are you letting all
your kids see the movie they I they have
all seen the movie they were wondering
where I'd been for three days I said oh
this is who wouldn't remember I was
kidnapped here's where I was and I've
showed my son my daughter was ten my
other son six all sawed definitely
acceptable you know acceptable
definitely acceptable which they brought
their friends so we had a nice kind of a
focus group and they thumbs-up from
everyone and and even better to be
honest which could not have been Ryan's
idea because this is very Canadian in
the spirit of you know Christmas and
charity and goodwill towards men you
know dollar of every ticket is being
donated to what the renaming fudge
cancer and so again not Ryan's idea I
don't want anyone oh he's great too
that was not Ryan's idea in fact I
overheard any fighting it but he lost
that argument and he every dollar of
every ticket sold goes to fudge cancer
which is which is wonderful that alone
is a reason to go you seem to sort of
handle the whole face of childhood
innocence you take it in stride is that
true I mean it was Ryan trying to derail
your career by taking you back to this
time or I think anyone who works with
Ryan Reynolds is taking their career in
their own hands you know I think they're
rolling a dice you know this could go
great or this could go bad and you know
we'll see it remains to be seen I feel
like you know there's a lot of broken
careers in the wake of Ryan Reynolds
and I just hope I don't join them I
don't know what did your kids think of
you being in The Wonder Years
they are like grandma shows it to us a
lot when we go to her house can we watch
the Goldbergs
they they like my kids they watch it a
little bit you know honestly my mom
shows in episodes for a while it was
kind of on on loop in our house and then
someone's like that's weird you should
turn that television watching so we
stopped but my kids know about The
Wonder Years and they like that I they
like that I am an actor and so you know
they just I think they will just want to
be home and wish that Ryan reals hadn't
kidnapped me if you leave we do they
just love me
you